par gignac et l'économiste en chef de
l'industrielle alliance à québec clément
gignac bonsoir bonsoir on sent la
nervosité pas mal plus de volatilité la
sur les marchés boursiers la chute
d'aujourd'hui nous signale quoi mais ça
signale qu'il ya vraiment beaucoup
d'incertitudes et nervosité parce que
comme vous savez la chaîne est devenue
beaucoup plus important que peuvent le
15 un exemple donc on parle quand même
que c'est 20 % de l'économie mondiale
c'est aussi pas loin de 700 millions
maintenant de passagers par année par
rapport à quelque chose comme 60
millions vlok une quinzaine d'années
donc la chine est devenu très important
même si c'est actuellement plutôt
limitant en chine on est inquiets du
côté des marchés qui est une forme de
propagation comme on avait observé en
2003 dans le code serait ce donc dans ce
sens là on est au tout début le
soi-disant évidemment il ya des choses
qui nous rassure parce que la chine est
beaucoup plus transparent mais néanmoins
il ya beaucoup d'incertitudes sur quel
sera l'impact puisque comme vous l'avez
mentionné l'impact du côté du tourisme
notamment est aussi ça pourrait avoir
d'impact sur la chaîne
d'approvisionnement mondiale
on voit l'impact aujourd'hui sur
plusieurs entreprises dans le secteur du
voyage de secteur du tourisme
on a vu aussi les taux obligataires ont
quand même en baisse pas mal aujourd'hui
les cours du pétrole en baisse le dollar
américain en hausse le prix de l'or en
hausse également
est-ce que ça envoie un signal comme
quoi finalement l'économie va ralentir
plus compenser ou parce qu'on voyait
quand même une projection de croissance
mondiale
un petit peu plus fort que l'an passé
mais l'a finalement est-ce qu'il va
falloir réviser tout cela mais en fait
ça pourrait reporter la reprise qu'on
pouvait observer peut-être qu'en
deuxième moitié d'année
faut bien penser qu'on a baissé taux
d'intérêt donc le maintenaient une trêve
commercial on en sait que vraiment les
disputes commerciales entre la chine et
les états unis avaient contribué au
ralentissement économique
mais lorsque aulas en fait la seule
référence qu'on a vraiment gerald comme
en économie c'est de retourner de mets
toi quand qu il ya des bonnes et
mauvaises nouvelles annoncées pour le
côté rassurant premièrement le taux de
mortalité beaucoup plus bord par de 2.52
points 8 % pour ceux qui ont affecté au
lieu de 10%
deuxièmement
chine colabor beaucoup mieux beaucoup
plus transparente suite avec des mesures
énergiques en partant par contre ça peut
prendre jusqu'à deux semaines avant
quelqu'un voit que se réalise que les
symptômes qui veulent avoir la taille et
qui plus est on a maintenant une
économie mondiale beaucoup plus intégré
le nombre de passagers maintenance et
4.2 milliards par année de touristes
versus 11.5 de 15 ans donc pour ça c'est
un peu prématuré savoir l'impact
meilleur un impact certain giral selon
moi sur l'économie mondiale mais quand
on regarde les chiffres de 2003 on a
parlé d'un impact mondial évalué à 40
milliards à cause du syndrome
respiratoire sévère le strass et un
effet de 0,1 pour cent sur le pib
mondial à l'époque
est-ce qu ici on est en train de
d'analysé des scénarios qui pourraient
être plus grave que ça en fait faudrait
bien pensé que si l'approbation c'est un
beau coup plus et on voit beaucoup plus
de corps du côté de l'europe du côté des
états unis reçoit l'aide des autorités
pourraient déclarer un peu comme c'était
le cas
quatre mois après le premier coque est
sorti et dans le code de mets toi sur le
stress que l'on n'est pas en risque
élevé on est en état d'urgence
l'organisation mondiale la santé décrété
un état d'urgence la ce a beaucoup
d'impact y compris dans un aéroport sous
le tourisme et le forez voir donc on
essaie prématuré à ce moment ci de voir
conclure si ça sera plus gros que de mes
doigts mais c'est sous haute
surveillance et surprendre promet plus
que deux trois jours ça va prendre
quelques semaines gerald selon - avant
de savoir vraiment si on fait face à
quelque chose qui est une épidémie
beaucoup plus importante
ou comparables à 2 mais toi mais que ce
soit plus important ou pas peu importe
les chiffres et est-ce qu'on va
constater dans les faits au cours des
prochaines semaines diriez vous que la
confiance qui est quand même au coeur du
fonctionnement économique que la
confiance est déjà affecté mais c'est
sûr que les marchés boursiers exemple
ces démarches et d'anticipation les
investisseurs voient en eux vu en 2003
la bourse qui réagit surtout du côté des
pays émergents
donc dans ce sens là ça peut
compromettre des projets de voyage dans
certains corps ou reporter à plus tard
donc c'est sûr c'est l'incertitude qui
peut déjà avoir un impact mais par
contre on voit que les autorités
médicales sont beaucoup mieux préparé
chen plus transparents et comme j'ai dit
plus tôt évidemment le taux de mortalité
est beaucoup plus faible donc pour les
gens qui nous regardent le brut et où le
risque que vous soyez affectés par ce
est relativement faible comme audi les
autorités médicales canadien oui c'est
vrai mais en même temps les gens qui
disent ah ben je vais je veux voyager ce
printemps je veux voyager l'été prochain
et des gens qui vont commencer à se
poser définition qui doivent le faire
aller se placer dans un centre alors
qu'on ne sait pas ce qui va se passer
exemple faut distinguer entre les les en
fait et les risques sont relativement
faibles de contracter le coronavirus
pour ceux qui nous regardent aujourd'hui
au canada mais les impacts économiques
eux sont faut pas les négliger parce que
ça peut compromettre des projets de
voyage on le voit les réactions à la
bourse mais aussi la chaîne
d'approvisionnement mondiale est
beaucoup plus intégrée connaît les
thèmes le quinze ans maintenant les
manufacturiers faut en faire beaucoup de
manufacturiers chinois
donc si tout à coup la chine comme c'est
annoncé récemment va prolonger peut-être
le congé extensions et des fermetures
d'usinés au delà du congé du nouvel an
mais là on va commencer à voir l'impact
l'économie l'économie mondiale il se
change la donne pour les banques
centrales dont la banque du canada
clairement c'est un facteur de risque on
peut il y avait des facteurs de région
politique celui-là on les jeux selon moi
savoir amener possiblement les banques
centrales à pouvoir être beaucoup plus
rapide et possiblement d'y aller d'un
assouplissement supplémentaire si jamais
les choses se détériorent où l'état de
propagation augmente on serait pas
surpris de voir les banques centrales
réagir aux besoins merci beaucoup pour
cette analyse clément gignac au plaisir
au revoir